[Music]
foreign
the actual Ayahuasca I gotta do that one
time with you I'd love to
yeah we can talk about it we can talk
about I mean I I know you'd give me the
authentic [ __ ] I don't want that like
[ __ ] I want to go if I'm gonna do
what's going on
I'm just gonna be like hold on let me
hop on Craigslist find somebody good
give me a second casual encounters does
that make sense I don't know how they're
advertising these days
I will say just as a quick note with
with Ayahuasca specifically
I talk so many more people out of using
well this is broadly speaking out of
using psychedelics than I have ever
talked into using psychedelics I think
that's something that a lot of folks
listening may not realize
that
I'm mostly disqualify or discourage
people from doing Ayahuasca or any
psychedelic
it just depends a lot on the specifics
for me because these things are so
strong and they can be
incredibly destable yeah I've been there
and after I did that high-dose mushrooms
very amazing experience and definitely
therapy like I should tell like they
tell you all compressedness little thing
but for two or three days after I was
just kind of like oh the Motions were
all over the place you know it's like
it's not just smooth sailing from the
second you get done you know the
chemicals are gonna rebalance and [ __ ]
yeah and you're
you're increasing plasticity so if you
take
you just imagine that you have like this
huge
let's just say maybe not huge like
volleyball sized ball of Play-Doh and
you have to heat it to be able to shape
it and that's your brain and then you
heat it and depending on all the inputs
and stimuli positive and negative that
enter your life or that you allow to
enter your life over the subsequent
handful of days or even weeks
will shape how that dries and then it's
not automatically for the better
so
long way of of saying definitely do your
homework this stuff has become so
popular and I'm excited about the
therapeutic potential I'm excited about
the
potential for examining
in ways that have been
effectively impossible before for a lot
of technological reasons we will begin
to ask and answer questions about the
mind and Consciousness itself that we
have not even been able to scratch the
surface of
in you know even even 20 years ago I
think I think Psychiatry is going to
fundamentally change a lot of really
core ways right I mean fundamental core
kind of redundant but you get the idea
that that some of the tectonic plates
under which Psychiatry rests currently
are going to shift very dramatically and
I'm excited about that yeah
sounds great I'm I'm speaking of which
you kind of we haven't even hit any of
our topics that we're gonna talk about
today well let me ask you before we move
on yeah it was going to be in line with
that but yeah we'll get there we'll get
there
now that you gave me one quarter of a
drink yeah hold on I love it I'm on a
roll I may or may not have had some
other chocolates oh that's right
I did not have that but in any case an
Ayahuasca chocolate well the old guys
that would be the most that would be
like cat [ __ ] sandwich is like the
flavor really comes to mind all right
why would you want to do say Ayahuasca
what would uh what would the the poll be
potentially
well I mean for me I I have had a few
experiences
on on psychedelics that every drug that
you take is a little bit different right
like you have a different door open
right like high-dose weed is going to
feel very different than high-dose
mushrooms because it's gonna feel very
different than microdosed acid which I'm
just talking about the things that I've
I've tried
so I imagine there's another door to
open there boofing ketamine different
door ketamine very different I've done
I've done ketamine before in a
therapeutic setting and it was it was it
was actually the most Pleasant like
chill thing I've ever done like this is
like just chill you know watch out for
the long-term brand damage if you guys
ever do it yeah we'll get into that in
another episode yeah so you know for me
I'm trying to figure out and this is on
onto my first point about my my seven
day Retreat that I'm gonna do well that
was a good head fake did you answer my
question no no no what I'm saying is
that I I wanna I wanna open as many
doors as possible during this lifetime
why not you know okay all right hey it's
not to say I'm gonna go in in and stick
to one door and be down that path for
the next you know six months but why not
just try it like I'm we're gonna be dead
in 40 years
true